you guys on the real Avengers
I can tell hope could get away with only
three next mission
I'll call you you have my numbers
someone will call you yeah
you're anybody's fight it's my chance to
prove myself
do me a favor stay close to the ground
oh nothing nothing
you're the spider-man from YouTube
Am I I'm suing I wasn't then what are
you doing in my room mailing me and you
said we're gonna finish at the stars and
nobody knows why me Missy still moves me
we're super death in Tony Stark Richard
are you want adventure
basically describe is even sweeter why
like if you find something we're trying
to me everything unless she's not let me
do this anymore
okay okay okay hey I'll level with you I
will do any distal sequence of reducing
rose ever happen to me I can't believe
this guard oh hey where you going what
are you hiding
Peter
I'm just kidding out okay hey everybody
it's Charlie a little bit of new footage
we get to see him do like a friendly
neighborhood spider-man safe just like
Iron Man
telling him someone will be in touch you
mean someone we have your number
he will not give up on being an Avenger
so I just keep wondering how long it's
actually going to be what he's going to
have to do before Iron Man's like okay
kid you're an Avenger or if it's going
to be one of those things where he just
gives him the suit at the end of the
movie and that sort of the sign that
he's become an Avenger like you won the
suit back because this seems like it's
happening relatively early in the build
but I should say there is a new round to
the Guardians giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video if you haven't
seen the movie already make sure you go
see it I know there are a lot of
questions that connect guardians to
Avengers through a couple of plot holes
but we're mostly focusing on Spider Man
I'll dress that stuff at the end of the
video because Tom Holland was talking
about future movies Peter quill is not
going to be coming to earth anytime soon
so the two Peters won't meet up for
quite a while but you see Iron Man
dropping off you see this funny save
scene at the rainbow this is your
friendly neighborhood spider-man you may
have seen behind the scenes pictures way
last summer when they were filming this
scene there were scenes of him on a
bicycle in the spider-man costume in
broad daylight
so people were like what's going on here
but then you saw the criminal hanging
from wires in the sky so you're like
okay
clearly he stole someone's bike he's
rescuing them there's a newsstand nearby
I wouldn't be surprised if we get a shot
of a Daily Bugle newspaper because a lot
of this movie feels like it takes place
in Queens so if we ever see the actual
Daily Bugle Jay jonah Jameson it
probably won't be for a while I think
it's mostly because they use them so
heavily in the other spider-man films
Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield and
they're really big on not doing
characters that they've already done but
I feel like The Daily Bugle now because
of the sharing arrangement with Sony can
become the de facto newspaper of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe at least for
the next couple of movies but most of
this interaction with the Daily Bugle
doesn't take place till he starts
swinging around Manhattan a whole lot
that doesn't really happen till much
later in his time as spider-man but I
think the fairy save will be like the
big hat tip like the big disaster but
here's the head scratcher Jay jonah
Jameson typically goes after spider-man
in the newspaper because he's the only
hero of the adventure but now because of
the MCU sharing arrangement you have all
these other Avengers flying around so
wouldn't the Daily Bugle be taking shots
at all the Avengers too so if the fairy
save goes sideways wouldn't Iron Man
also make that headline it feels like
one of those sales tactics where like
you put Tony Stark on the front of a
paper it'll sell way faster than if you
put this brand new spider-man person on
the front of the paper so I'm just not
expecting to see a whole lot of that but
I'm sure that they'll find a funny way
to work The Daily Bugle into the movie
but the other really funny part here's
him swinging through the backyard
chasing down a criminal in falling next
to this tent with the little girls in it
in his math just malfunctioning so the
IPS just starts twitching like he's
totally possessed by a demon oh my god
it's not that he's swinging through a
backyard just for fun he's actually
trying to chase down a criminal for real
it's just you don't see the criminal
part but if it wasn't clear what the
villain progression is in the movie you
start out with him in the suit early in
the movie stopping bank robberies stuff
like that but he sees that they're using
shatori tech then he sees criminals
doing worse and worse things with even
more dangerous weapons you see the
tinkerer and the Shocker building even
more dangerous weapons from cobbled
together bits of other alien parts then
you get to your fairy save and he tries
to tell Iron Man look we have this big
problem there's a lot of weapons
manufacturing going on and then you
legit starts going up against the
vulture who's
behind all these weapons sales really I
think the thing that's different about
this spider-man movie other than him
being in high school is the fact that
somebody knows his secret identity and
is going to be helping him be spider-man
or at least learn to be a better
spider-man part of the whole thing with
Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield is that
people don't know his secret and then
over the course of a couple movies they
slowly find out Mary Jane didn't learn
to the second movie and neither one of
them really helped Peter out but you
have meta leads here who's discovering
these spider-man for the first time and
then in later clips you see him help
hack the suit to learn what all the
different stark tech does so you don't
really see it too much in like the later
footage like he has that big save where
he's wearing the old version of the suit
but I think a big part of the movie is
in him leaning on his friends and then
helping him be a better spider-man so
it'll be fun to see how they help out
with like the big big later fights in
the film when he's going up against the
vulture because they are really selling
a spider team and I'm interested to see
if Michelle finds out by the end of the
movie too because they're just implying
that she's a little bit smarter than
previous Spiderman love interest but
she's a little more observant even if
she's pretending not to be Peter where
are you going just kidding I totally
don't give a crap so it almost feels
like she's gonna find out by the end of
the movie - but the cool thing is that
we know that there's going to be a
second spider-man homecoming movie Tom
Holland did this big fan event in Brazil
where he talked about the villains that
they're looking at and stuff that he's
really excited to do he named drop
Mysterio talked about some of the other
villains that he wants to do in the
future so I'll read his quote here he
says there's so many good villains I
really like Mysterio I like Kraven I
really like the Clone Saga I think it
would be really cool if Peter or
spider-man has to fight people with the
same powers as him Spider Woman super
cool I think she's called Spider Girl
who is his clone they kind of like hit
it off and then they take their masks
off and they're like oh my god what the
hell they're like the same person but
she's just a girl I think that's really
cool so he's talking about a bunch of
different things but you know we talk
about how spider-man homecoming is
borrowing a lot from The Ultimates comic
when he talks about the Spider Woman
that's a clone of spider-man that's
actually the Jessica drew character from
The Ultimates universe so main universe
Jessica drew is a completely different
character but it definitely implies that
they are borrowing heavily for all this
I'm an homecoming movies even the sequel
from The Ultimates universe Kraven is a
solid pick but most of the villains that
they gone with so far are tech based
like the vulture is very tech based even
though in the comics there's a couple
different versions of him and even
though his flight harness is something
the EO is engineers it looks more
bird-like as opposed to the more tech
based Iron Man look of the new Spider
Man homecoming films so just assume if
they do animal based villains because
that's what most of spider-man's
villains are they will have a tech spin
on them the Quentin Beck Mysterio would
be perfect for that because he was just
a stunt man that used technology to make
it seem like he was working magic but I
don't know if he's quite a big enough
character to be like the big villain of
a movie like the vulture is the big bat
of spider-man homecoming the Shocker is
a big spider-man villain but he's not
the big bat he's working with the
vulture so it feels like if they did
Mysterio or Kraven they would do a
situation like that where there's a
couple villains working together but let
me know like who do you want the big bad
of the next spider-man movie to be the
other big news you may have heard about
this is actually pretty cool there's
going to be a Deadpool TV series and
everybody's already asked what it's
going to be rated they're calling it an
adult TV series so I'll do a video
explaining what's going on with that but
congratulations to squid bear you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message be on the back end of my channel
so it can get your contact details you
can click here for all my Guardians
Easter eggs and you can click here for a
longer spider-man trailer thank you so
much for watching let's have five I'll
see you guys tonight
you